at the height of the cold war space race
a launch pad fire killed three apollo
astronauts it was the first tragedy of
the american space program
this week more than half a century later
the accident the crew of apollo 1 was
honored with a monument at arlington
national cemetery chris van cleave
reports
decades ago
cape canaveral's launch complex 34 sits
in a seemingly somber silence
largely off limits to the public
it's where the first american lives were
lost reaching for the stars is this
hollowed ground
this is this is hollowed ground because
of the tragedy of apollo 1 and the three
lives lost here jamie draper is the
director of the air force space and
missile museum the incident really shook
not only the space program but america
to the court on january 27 1967
three weeks before the launch the crew
of apollo 1 suited up and arrived here
for a dress rehearsal inside their
command module 218 feet atop a saturn 1b
rocket mission commander gus grissom a
veteran of the mercury and gemini
missions senior pilot ed white the first
american to walk in space and roger
chaffee a respected navy pilot training
for his first space flight orbiting the
earth in the new apollo capsule
but three hours into the test
disaster
this is a cbs news special report
america's first three apollo astronauts
were trapped and killed by a flash fire
that swept their moonship early tonight
during a launch pad test
at cape kennedy in florida the capsule
had been pressurized with pure oxygen a
spark from faulty electrical wiring
likely ignited the flash fire it took
five minutes for rescuers to open the
hatch by then it was too late again just
days before the fatal fire grissom spoke
to cbs news the possibility of a
catastrophic failure bother you at all
sir
no you sort of have to put that out of
your mind
you'll just plan as best you can to take
care of
all of these eventualities
and you get a well-trained crew and you
go fly
though the country asked itself whether
the moon was worth this human cost the
apollo program pressed on
[Music]
less than two years after the apollo 1
incident apollo 7 launched from this
complex with all of the lessons learned
from apollo 1 incorporated and it led to
apollo 8 eventually apollo 11 without
their sacrifice the program would not
have been reconfigured and we would not
have made it to the moon go with
throttle up
but tragedy struck nasa again in 1986
obviously a major malfunction
columbia houston comcheck
and 2003. lock the doors copy the 14
lives lost in the space shuttle
challenger and columbia accidents were
honored with memorials at arlington
national cemetery
but not apollo 1 even though grissom and
chaffee were laid to rest there decades
earlier it was an easy visual to see
this is missing lance bush runs the
challenger center founded by the
families of that shuttle accident in
2015 he and many in the space community
started pushing for an apollo 1 monument
at arlington if you ask somebody what's
this country's greatest achievements i
mean
i'm certain that walking on the moon is
going to be in the top three but that
was built on the shoulders of a lot of
people and a lot of sacrifice in the
apollo 1 crew
it's a
really important story and that can be
told there at arlington finally this
week 55 years after the accident apollo
1 story got its missing chapter
a new memorial to the crew was dedicated
thursday on hand where chaffey's
daughter cheryl white's daughter bonnie
and grissom's brother lowell
well it was
very solemn long time coming
it's very nice that we can finally get
this done this is all so appropriate for
all three of the guys and i'm very very
proud of my dad and i just sort of
wanted
to have everybody remember all three you
know they were family men
but they were professionals they were
daring and
they had fun
you know
they were just just great people and i
would like to see people really go and
look
into who they were in designing the
monument the families had one request a
latin motto carved in stone at astra per
aspera a rough road leads to the stars a
message of perseverance that helps carry
man to the moon
for cbs saturday morning chris van
cleave cape canaveral florida
wow
looking at launch complex 34 there i
mean it's eerie but it's straight it's
beautiful in a way when you understand
what's happened
now at arlington and people forget how
how much that mission apollo 1 changed
every all the apollos to come after it i
mean as a child i always wondered okay
there was apollo 1 and then the moon
launch was apollo 11.
what went in between i now know
a lot dude
and as they said it is about time